y dónde desarrollo procesos
que investigan posibles mezclas sensoriales del futuro.
Creo que es dónde se cruzan la filosofía y la tecnología.
Hacer este trabajo me enseñó un par de cosas.
Me enseñó cómo aceptar la imperfección
en realidad puede enseñarnos algo de nosotros mismos.
Me enseñó que explorar el arte
puede ayudarnos a moldear la tecnología que nos moldea.
Y me enseñó que combinando AI y robótica
con formas tradicionales de creatividad, artes visuales en mi caso,
puede enseñarnos a pensar un poco más profundamente
sobre qué es un humano y qué es la máquina.
Y me ha llevado a entender
que la colaboración es la clave para crear un espacio para ambos
a medida que avanzamos.
Todo comenzó con un simple experimento con máquinas.
llamado "Drawing Operations Unit: Generation 1"
Llamé a la máquina D.O.U.G, para abreviar.
Antes de construir a D.O.U.G
nos sabía nada sobre construir robots.
Tomé algunos diseños de brazo robótico de código abierto,
hackeé un sistema en el que el robot copiaba mis gestos
y los seguía en tiempo real.
La premisa era simple:
Yo dirigiría y él seguiría.
Yo dibujaría una línea y él imitaría mi línea.
En 2015 allí estábamos, dibujando por primera vez,
en frente de una pequeña audiencia en Nueva York.
El proceso fue bastante austero,
sin luces, sin sonido, nada para esconderse.
Solo mis manos sudando y los servomotores del robot calentándose.
(Ríe) Claramente, no estábamos hechos para esto.
Pero ocurrió algo interesante, algo que no anticipé.
Verán, D.O.U.G, en su forma primitiva no seguía mi línea perfectamente
Mientras que en la simulación que ocurrió en la pantalla
era perfecto,
en la realidad física, era una historia diferente.
Se resbalaba y deslizaba, se interrumpía y vacilaba,
y yo debía responder.
No había nada puro al respecto.
Y aún, de algún modo, los errores hicieron mi trabajo más interesante.
La máquina interpretaba mi línea, pero no perfectamente.
Y yo debía responder.
Nos adaptábamos el uno al otro en tiempo real.
Y ver esto me enseñó un par de cosas.
Me enseñó que nuestros errores hacen el trabajo más interesante.
Y me di cuenta de que, a través de la imperfección de la máquina,
nuestras imperfecciones se convirtieron en lo que era hermoso de la interacción.
Y estaba emocionada, porque me llevó a darme cuenta
de que quizás parte de la belleza de los sistemas humano y máquina
es su inherente falibilidad compartida.
Para la segunda generación de D.O.U.G,
supe que quería explorar esta idea.
Pero en lugar de un accidente provocado
al llevar al brazo robótico a su límite,
quería diseñar un sistema que respondiera a mis dibujos
de formas que no esperaba.
Así que usé un algoritmo visual para extraer información visual
de décadas de mis dibujos digitales y analógicos.
Entrené una red neuronal con estos dibujos
para generar patrones recurrentes en el trabajo
que luego se introdujeron a través de software personalizado a la máquina.
Recopilé minuciosamente tantos dibujos como pude encontrar,
trabajos acabados, experimentos sin terminar y bocetos aleatorios,
y los etiqueté para el sistema IA.
Y como soy artista, llevo trabajando más de 20 años.
Recopilar tantos dibujos llevó meses,
fue un montón.
Y aquí está la cuestión sobre entrenar sistemas AI:
en realidad es mucho trabajo duro.
Hay mucho trabajo detrás de escena.
Pero al hacer el trabajo, aprendí un poco más
sobre cómo se construye la arquitectura de un IA.
Y noté que no solo está hecho de modelos y clasificadores
para la red neuronal.
Sino que es un sistema fundamentalmente maleable y moldeable,
en el que la mano humana siempre está presente.
Está lejos de la IA omnipotente en la que nos han dicho que creamos.
Así que recopilé estos dibujos para la red neuronal.
Y nos dimos cuenta de algo que antes no era posible.
Mi robot D.O.U.G se convirtió en una reflexión interactiva a tiempo real
del trabajo que había realizado a lo largo de mi vida.
Los datos eran personales, pero los resultados fueron poderosos.
Y me emocioné mucho,
porque empecé a pensar que quizás las máquinas no son solo herramientas,
sino que pueden funcionar como colaboradores no humanos.
Y aún más que eso,
pensé que tal vez el futuro de la creatividad humana
no está en lo que hace
sino cómo se une para explorar nuevas maneras de crear.
Si D.O.U.G_1 fue el músculo,
y D.O.U.G_2 fue el cerebro,
entonces me gustaría pensar en D.O.U.G_3 como la familia.
Sabía que quería explorar esta idea de colaboración entre humanos
y no-humanos a escala.
En los últimos meses,
trabajé con mi equipo para desarrollar 20 robots personalizados
que trabajarían conmigo como colectivo.
Trabajarían como un grupo
y juntos colaboraríamos con todo Nueva York.
Me inspiró mucho el investigador de Stanford Fei-Fei Li,
quien dijo: "Si queremos enseñar a las máquinas a pensar,
primero debemos enseñarles cómo ver".
Me hizo pensar en la última década de mi vida en Nueva York
y cómo nos vigilan todas esas cámaras de seguridad por la ciudad.
Y pensé que sería realmente interesante
si pudiera usarlas para enseñar a mis robots a ver.
Con este proyecto,
pensé sobre la mirada de la máquina,
y empecé a pensar sobre la visión multidimensional,
como vistas de alguna parte.
Recopilamos videos
de las cámaras públicas disponibles en internet,
de gente caminando por las aceras,
autos y taxis en la carretera,
todo tipo de movimiento urbano.
Entrenamos un algoritmo de la visión con esas fuentes
basado en una técnica llamada "flujo óptico",
para analizar la densidad colectiva,
dirección, permanencia y velocidad del movimiento urbano.
Nuestro sistema extrajo esos estados de las fuentes como datos posicionales
y se voliveron cuadernos para dibujar para mis unidades robóticas.
En lugar de una colaboración uno a uno,
hicimos una colaboración de muchos a muchos.
Combinando la visión de los humanos y las máquinas en la ciudad,
reimaginamos lo que podría ser una pintura de un paisaje.
En todos mis experimentos con D.O.U.G,
no hay dos actuaciones que hayan sido iguales.
Y a través de la colaboración
creamos algo que ninguno podría haber hecho solo
exploramos los límites de nuestra creatividad,
humano y no humano trabajando en paralelo.
Creo que es solo el principio.
Este año, lancé Scilicet,
mi nuevo laboratorio explorando la interración humana e interhumana.
Estamos muy interesados en la retroalimentación
entre sistemas individuales, artificiales y ecológicos.
Conectamos la producción humana y máquina
con datos biométricos y otros tipos de datos ambientales.
Invitamos a cualquiera interesado en el futuro del trabajo, sistemas
y colaboración interhumana
a investigar con nosotros.
Sabemos que no solo los tecnólogos tienen que hacer este trabajo
y que todos tenemos un papel que desempeñar.
Creémos que enseñando a las máquina
cómo hacer el trabajo tradicionalmente hecho por humanos.
podemos explorar y desarrollar nuestro criterio
de lo que ha hecho posible la mano humana.
Y parte de ese viaje es aceptar las imperfecciones
y reconocer la falibilidad tanto humana y máquina,
para expandir el potencial de ambos.
Hoy sigo buscando la belleza
en la creatividad humana y no humana.
En el futuro, no tengo ni idea de cómo será esto,
pero tengo mucha curiosidad por descubrirlo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)